you're excited about this one yeah
welcome back she's been checking this
out the whole branch i know it's like
it's making me nervous it's not even
real
all right welcome back everybody you are
listening to colombian superstar
sebastian yatra yeah and that is his hit
song tacones rojos featuring vegas
headliner john legend and this weekend
las vegas is being serenaded
by singer songwriter and academy award
nominee sebastian yatra our senior
producer in las vegas now in espanol
host natalia masanedo talked with yatra
about his north american tour titled
dharma check it out
it's going to be my first experience in
vegas
doing a show by myself so that's
definitely something exciting for me
because in vegas the crowd is crazy and
you can expect people from all over the
world
[Music]
you gonna be all right yeah yeah yeah
all right all right the after will be
taking over the chelsea theater stage
this saturday night and here's what he
says you can expect from his show
you can expect to connect to feel a lot
of things in this show it's not a show
about
me it's very interactive and the show
has
something for
all of those uh moments that we go
through in life and it's it's really
cool and it's two hours of non-stop good
energy
and good looks we'll hear more from
sebastian yatra in tomorrow's show as he
talks about his collab with vegas
headliner john legend and upcoming
projects that's very cool again
sebastian nyacha takes over the chelsea
theater stage inside the cosmopolitan
this saturday night there are still
tickets available through ticketmaster